Brad found out this afternoon that you
were going to be available ultimately
what did it come down to to make you
feel comfortable that you were able to
make your return uh I mean obviously
just being able
to be myself in some ways you know being
able to push off my ankle get to my step
back being able to be in Rhythm and play
without thinking about it and so last
two weeks have been good uh thankful I
didn't go the whole three three weeks
but uh it was definitely a task and I'm
just happy to be back Big Time
facilitator for you tonight with those
seven assists what were you looking to
see out of yourself tonight in your
return I was just trying to find my
rhythm I know it's still I'm still
figuring the offense out I'm still
adjusting still learning how to play
with these guys and I don't want to be I
still need to be a little bit more
aggressive I was probably a little bit
too passive tonight um but for the most
part I just wanted to make sure that I
one finish the game and then two just
making sure that I was getting a rhyth
them as best as I could yeah what is the
key to finding that balance being
aggressive while also at the same time
being patient while you're making your
way back uh I mean it's a it's a fine
line I mean obviously being smart with
decision making of driving to the basket
and being in clouded crowded areas for
right now but uh I'm still I still have
to be I still to be myself I got to be
aggressive uh I'm just thankful that
we're full strength we got all our guys
back uh and it was a totally different
team tonight we had a lot more space a
lot more open shooting uh our defense
was a little bit trash but you know we
we will continue to get that better
we're glad to have you back thank you
thank it's good to be back thanks for
your time
yeah